[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec la même solennité qui avait entouré
ses funérailles voici 26 ans lyautey
aura quitté cette terre marocaine qu'il
avait tenté mais et à laquelle il avait
consacré la plus belle part de sa
volonté et de son esprit en présence
d'une foule dans laquelle se mêlaient
les visages française et marocains le
cercueil passant des mains de l'armée
marocaine aux mains des marins français
a été déposée pour son dernier voyage
sur la plage arrière du colbert le plus
beau bâtiment de la flotte française
yoplait
c'est un nom et un visage le nom et le
visage de l'homme qui sut donner un
avenir moderne à un pays resté au rythme
du moyen-âge ces images de 1912 retrace
quelques instants de l'action grandiose
qui fit d'une terre dit viser un royaume
pacifié et d'une nature hostile le plus
beau domaine de l'afrique du nord
pacificateur lyautey nous à pâques des
armes en portant au sultanat le jeune
mohamed ben youssef qui devait devenir
le roi mohamed 5
il assura le pouvoir central jusqu'à
leur discuter bâtisseurs d'empiré
politique il fut en même temps le
constructeur matériel d'un pays
la pioche et la truelle furent ses
outils préférés
mais cette fièvre de constructeurs et
d'ouvreur de route ne lui fit jamais
perdre de vue la personnalité du pays
qu'il transformait il sut conserver les
usages les traditions les rides
profondes de ce maroc auquel ils
enlevaient les bandelettes qui leur
tenait en marge des grands routes
modernes il le fait si bien qu il pu
dans un temps de troubles et sur un
territoire non pas s'y fier entrez dans
fais presque sans escorte au milieu des
pèlerins et se mêler au fait qui
accompagne chaque année le pèlerinage de
moulay idriss
[Musique]
créateur au vu large il eu l'audace
d'organiser deux ans après la soumission
de la ville
la foire de fès qui devait par la suite
devenir l'une des manifestations
économiques les plus importantes du
maroc et joindre même assez aux soucis
d'avenir
un grain de fantaisie et de souris
[Musique]
c'est ce lyautey le bâtisseur d'empiré
comme on le nomma qui revient en france
les circonstances ne permettent pas
toujours aux hommes de décider à jamais
ni de leur destin ni de leur tombeau
mais lyautey restera toujours présent au
maroc et il n'y a pour le savoir qu'à
regarder ce qu'il a fait d'un coin de
côte où il n'y avait rien casablanca
au milieu d'un parterre d'amis du cinéma
pierre blanchard qu'entouraient la
petite fille de georges méliès et de
nombreuses personnalités a célébré à la
mairie de montreuil le centenaire de la
naissance de l'homme qui fut le créateur
du film romancée c'est à montreuil en
effet que méliès construisit les
premiers studios de cinéma à cette place
qu'occupe aujourd'hui une scierie c'est
là que de 1896 à 1922 fut retournée près
de 4000 films parmi lesquels ce voyage
dans la lune qui fit courir en 1902 les
foules de l'époque les super productions
d'aujourd'hui sont loin de ses débuts
mais elles ne font que développer ce qui
était en puissance dans ses productions
qu'on regarde comme enfantine à méliès
revient la gloire d'avoir le premier
déceler toutes les possibilités du
septième art d'avoir inventé le récit
cinématographique
la mise en scène le trucage le décor il
n'en profita pas et mûri peau saluons le
centenaire de georges méliès
ce fut un grand monsieur
[Musique]
l'invasion de cuba par les anti
castristes s'est soldée par un échec
un raid aérien sur la havane avait
marqué le début des opérations
fidel castro avait en pleurant des
victimes charger les états unis de la
responsabilité de la faire
à miami un bombardier cubain atteint par
la dc avait disposé et son équipage
disait s'être rebellé contre castro
l'attaqué puis la défaite des
anticastristes ont eu un retentissement
considérable
les cubains exilés à miami ont manifesté
contre le régime de fidel castro à
moscou a eu lieu une manifestation
monstre appuyant des accusations de
castro contre les états unis
ces accusations qu'a réagi le président
kennedy en exprimant que l'amérique ne
tolérerait pas indéfiniment une menace
communiste à 150 km de ses côtes
avant de vivre les heures dramatiques
que l'on sait la france avait reçu le
sénégal de l'elysée où le président
senghor était l'hôte du général de
gaulle au château de champs où le
général de gaulle était l'hôte du
président senghor trois journées ont
permis de constater la réalité d'une
amitié née voici trois siècles est
perpétuée par delà l'indépendance
proclamée il ya un an
[Musique]
au terme de cette visite une soirée de
gala devait être donnée à la
comédie-française en l'honneur du
président de la république sénégal est
[Musique]
oh
et
ayant deux soirées ou bien des visages
n'était pas inconnu à l'ancien membre du
gouvernement français que fut monsieur
léopold sédar senghor
[Musique]
le calme d'alger était trompeur
soudainement alger a basculé dans un
drame qui agite aujourd'hui la france et
au delà des frontières le nom d' attaché
à la solution du problème algérien mise
en route par le général de gaulle les
français ont soudain découvert le
gouffre ou risquait de s'enliser le pays
lorsqu'elle est visée à la sortie d'un
conseil des ministres convoqué d'urgence
la nouvelle fut annoncée et que le
ministre de l'information monsieur louis
terrenoire déclara aux journalistes a
été décidé de déférer à la justice
militaire
les généraux challe salle en jouant et
zeller ainsi que le colonel godard à ce
moment le général salah en espagne
combiner son départ pour alger
le pouvoir était tombé au map de quatre
généraux qui s'était saisie d'alger puis
dorrans enfin de constantine le délégué
général monsieur jean morin étaient
prisonniers des rebelles ainsi que le
général gambie est commandante en chef
monsieur louis joxe ministre de
l'algérie après une mission de 24 heures
revenait à l'elysée faire son rapport et
les français au soir du 23 avril
entendait à la radio la voix du général
de gaulle au nord de la france j'en dors
que tous les moyens jeudi tous mes
moyens soit employé partout pour barrer
la route à ces hommes là en attendant de
les réduire
j'interdis à tout français est d'abord à
tout soldat d'exécuter aucun de leurs
chambres françaises français voyez où
risque d'aller la france par rapport à
ce qu'elle était en train de re de vie
françaises français
elio noir
pour compléter leur chance les rebelles
tenterait-il un raid sur paris dans la
nuit une dramatique partie se déroulait
où le sort de la nation était en jeu des
chars prenez position au poids
stratégique et le peuple de paris était
appelé à tenir son rôle dans ce drame
inattendu c'est par milliers qu'ont pu
compter les engagements réclamés pour
secondes et les forces de l'ordre
le gouvernement avait pris ces mesures
de sauvegarde est assurée la sécurité
nationale
le jeu se leva sur une floraison de
titres dramatique
[Musique]
vide sur les aérodromes tout trafic
était suspendu
il devait reprendre partiellement
piste qui demeure évident prête à être
encombré de camions pour empêcher tout
atterrissage
à la nuit de fièvre avait succédé une
journée de fiers une grève d'une heure
marquée la décision des centrales
syndicales d'aidé dans son oeuvre le
chef de l'état et 7h d'inaction fut le
signe le plus évident de l'accord
national
pendant une heure d'un consentement
général tout s'arrêta ce référendum
d'année les autres la france tout
entière en ces heures lourdes a marqué
qu'elle était d'accord avec son chef
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]